foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
good morning
it's Tuesday
taco Tuesday it's normally Texas called
Tuesday as well but Texas Paul is on the
road you know he went to DC
so he's still on the road he'll probably
be joining us next week you know last
week we talked about this that he would
be um he had something secret that was
going on and now we know he went to the
White House
so um which is super awesome hopefully
Texas ball can come next week and we can
talk on Tuesday about his trip to DC
and his travels across the country and
to the ultimate cussing Pond I don't
know if you've seen his video or not
so
this morning
we have a loser a big loser Ron DeSantis
and of course we're going to we're going
to talk about and look at the clips from
the Rhonda santis Charlie Crist
debate which it wasn't much of a debate
um Charlie Crist only asked one question
that needed to be asked for Floridians
which is Rhonda Santos do you plan on
being governor for four years are you
actually running for the job that you
say you're running for or is it
something different that you're doing
and he wouldn't answer so we're going to
watch those clips but first off I want
to talk first about Leslie Jordan
apparently Leslie passed away
in a car accident yesterday Leslie
Jordan is one of the great performers of
our country
he's one of the great voices of our time
he's a great comedian singer dancer
actor
and just a decent great human being
and I I truly believe that it is a huge
loss
to not just the entertainment Community
but this country as a whole to lose
someone like Leslie Jordan who has such
a big heart
and I think we'll definitely play some
Leslie Jordan videos today but um when
everyone found out about his passing
yesterday it was um quite the shock
because it was um
something you don't expect I've lost
some family members to some automobile
accidents and um my heart goes out to
Leslie and his family but the the great
part is is that Leslie has left us with
a legacy of laughter a legacy of
entertainment and we should we should
honor him by enjoying that today so I
plan on playing several Leslie Jordan
videos and of course the infamous whale
[ __ ] video
um here my co-host Gabe Sanchez
[Music]
um
actually posted a video that video that
very video so we will we will
um
talk about Leslie Jordan today I think
it's uh he's a bright spot
in our country and it's a it's it's a
shame that um that he went so early but
um again he left us with a legacy of
laughter and entertainment so
um we thank Leslie for all the laughs
and entertainment that he's given us
throughout the years so I I do want to
um give my condolences though to Leslie
and um there was another sudden death
Ash Carter had passed away as well
um the member of the Obama
Administration will probably get that
to that today as well I was supposed to
have the ballot Dropbox none on today
but the scheduling did not work out we
thought it was going to work but it did
not so hopefully we'll have her tomorrow
joining us
um by phone she did several interviews
with CNN and a few others
um so I did speak with her yesterday to
do a sound test but she wasn't sure
about the time so but she did tell me
this morning we'd have to probably
reschedule so I apologize for not having
her on today but we we will try to get
her back on here and ask her questions
about her approaching these Dropbox
Intimidators the the the Maga terrorists
that are trying to intimidate voters
which again this doesn't make much sense
that they are trying to secure the most
secure drop boxes that there are
and I don't understand it really I mean
if they want to have an argument that
they're not intimidating voters they
would be securing
boxes for all voters and protecting
ballots
um not doxing people and taking pictures
of people and really the motives here
look criminal
um and I don't know if
it's going to turn that way
um if law enforcement gets a hold of the
evidence that what the motives and the
intent is behind the voter intimidation
but if that is the case oh boy and they
may be in trouble they may be in some
real serious and treble
so we'll we'll get that smoked out
um there's a couple court news
apparently Tom Barrick said in court
that um
Trump destroyed his businesses yet no
[ __ ] Sherlock everything Trump touches
turns the liquid [ __ ]
um another courtroom uh news report this
morning is that Stuart Rhodes has waived
his right to be inside the courtroom
apparently his attorneys had confirmed
with him in person that he would be
willing to waive his right as a few
Witnesses were being questioned in the
open court
and I I guess the judge this morning was
talking to Stuart on speakerphone and he
did confirm to the judge that yes he is
okay with the court proceeding and which
you know he has that right to be or not
to be in the court room while they're
having those proceedings so and Stuart
Rhodes has covet and my condolences to
covet
um so much someone put that in the
comments the other day I think that's um
I think that's fantastic I think that's
fantastic but we got a lot of video to
get to today but I do want to I do want
to tell you that um yesterday after the
debate with Ron DeSantis and Charlie
Crist that I want to give all the
naysayers out there and really you know
who the [ __ ] you are
You Know Who You Are you you you are
pro-democracy people but you still are
sowing doubt within the pro-democracy
camp
you know who you are you're both siding
things you're saying Charlie Chris died
he's not really interested in this race
he's not willing to fight he just ain't
in it to win it he thinks Ron DeSantis
is going to win this hurricane thing and
blah blah blah [ __ ] blah it's all
bull-side [ __ ]
it's all defeatism
and I want to tell you that I'm here to
push back on it
100 to push back on it Charlie Chris did
not show last night that he he thinks
he's defeated in any shape form of the
manner
last night Ron DeSantis got his ass
stomped in a debate by one simple
question and one question alone
are you going
to take this job as Governor to continue
to be governor
now there's a lot of Great Clips in this
debate
and we watched as these debates have you
know over the last several weeks have
rolled out uh where Tim Ryan absolutely
bent JD Vance over his knee and whipped
him
and we we watched
uh the debate with Val demmings and
Marco Rubio her dressing him down in
Florida
and we watched as Herschel Walker pulled
out a fake badge as if that was going to
help him in Georgia
um I don't I don't really understand
that like
he thinks it's a good thing for him to
be a fake cop like I I just don't
understand how we think that's how
Herschel Walker believes that's good for
Georgia that you're a fake cop
I don't understand it
um as these early election results start
to show it's showing that yes yes people
are motivated to vote especially in
Georgia especially in Atlanta
and they're willing to wait in line for
hours and hours and hours to make sure
their ballot is cast now
now so many people posting out there on
social media that they cast their ballot
early keep doing it keep pressing
keep showing these [ __ ] Maga
terrorists who we are that we will not
stop we will not relent we are not going
to let them intimidate us
into not voting keep dropping those
ballots in the secure boxes mail in your
ballot go vote early if you can
if your state allows it
it is crucial that we vote now
now
there's always going to be doubt that
they're going to spread
so
again to the naysayers out there the
same naysayers who said Charlie Christ
has already given up on this race he's
gonna let DeSantis win
are gonna be the same naysayers that are
gonna say [ __ ] like well they're just
gonna so doubt and they're gonna
challenge the election apparently Trump
has already got attorneys in
Pennsylvania who gives a [ __ ]
who gives a flying [ __ ] what they're
gonna Challenge and how they're gonna
challenge it
we have great election attorneys on our
side
Mark Elias being one of the greatest
and they're not going to quit for you
Mark is working for the American people
to make sure that that the election is
not fraudulently challenged
there are great election attorneys on
the pro-democracy side that are out to
defend democracy and yes they need your
help but how they need your help is you
have to engage and you have to go vote
you have to use your ballot
as The Voice
but use your voice as well you don't
have to just stop at boating
you can you can make sure that your
friends your family your colleagues
your fellow parishioners at your church
the people on the PTA with you
are also considering and gonna go vote
it is super important that the turnout
is high
and not just because turnout
when it is high benefits Democrats the
pro-democracy party the only
pro-democracy party at this point
we have to show them how [ __ ]
motivated we are to to participate and
engage in democracy because that's what
they're scared of
they're terrified
terrified that you the people
the votes
will be stacked against them in every
election from now until Kingdom Come
because they're not going to relent even
if we pile them under mountains of votes
they're still going to lie they're still
going to [ __ ] their supporters
and they're still going to continue to
capitulate to the orange Mussolini Jesus
because it's good for grifting
essentially
it's good for grifting
but let me ask you if you really look at
the the political landscape
how much have you heard from Mitch
McConnell lately
have you heard much from him
seen much tape on him talking about how
they're going to win the election and
he's excited and he can't wait to go
stunt for these candidates and he can't
wait to be the majority leader of the
Senate have you heard much Adam Mitch
mcconnelly
nope
not a goddamn thing
silence
you know what you want to know the
reason why
Mitch McConnell not only knows that he's
going to lose
Mitch McConnell wants to lose
that's right Mitch McConnell wants these
Trump supporting
candidates and these Trump endorse
candidates to lose Mitch McConnell has
to prove that Donald Trump is the loser
that Ron DeSantis was in the in the
debate last night
think about this for a second let's say
let's say that Trump takes credit for
the for the Senate
going to the majority of Republicans
just bear with me for a second
let's say Herschel Walker picks up his
seat Blake Masters wins in Arizona
that will give the majority
Mitch McConnell will be the majority
leader of what
the Republicans
or the trumpers
see Mitch McConnell does not want to be
second fiddle to Donald Trump
he never has been
that's why he was kind of excited about
Donald Trump in the beginning him and
Paul Ryan back in 2016 because they
thought it was just a wet pin
a buffoon and a seat in a suit that
would sign anything
and essentially in the beginning that
was true
he was the buffoon in a suit that would
sign anything anything they did of
course they couldn't do anything because
they don't know how to govern
they're worthless
the Republican party over the last three
decades has put themselves in the
situation where they absolutely only
know how to obstruct
that is it that is their only play in
policy is to obstruct
they yell and scream about gas prices
absolutely do nothing about it yell and
scream about inflation but not one
Senator will show up to a committee
meeting about Invasion not [ __ ] one
of them
half their caucus is internet trolls
they're not they're not even they're not
even real politicians they're not even
interested in real policy only in their
social media accounts
that's it
which has led them into a direction of
insurrection
a party of domestic terrorists
and it is going to take a long time for
them to unwind that they did that to
themselves
for the eight years under Barack Obama
for the for the four years under Trump
and now the two years of lying under
Biden has led them in this position
and they're gonna pay for it
they're gonna pay for it there's always
consequences to your actions always
good bad or indifferent there's always
consequences
and when you watch
armed individuals in masks
intimidating voters to place their
ballots
in the most secure Dropbox that possibly
it can be placed in
to intimidate voters not to vote because
that's what they're scared of they're
terrified of it the reason why they have
these people brainwashed into going and
committing crime
in the in
in the in the guys the patriotism and
saving our democracy saving the Republic
it's Criminal
especially if the motive is Criminal
now these people brainwashed into doing
this garbage
these people are not coupled to reality
but you must be and you must know what's
at stake I was talking to a friend
yesterday
and he called me he was concerned
he was concerned because the media keeps
saying that the polls are so close and
it's so close that historically the
party that is that is in power and the
first midterm is the is the one who
loses
and so we are not we are not
in a time that is the same as it was six
years ago
12 years ago
20 years ago this is not the 1990s this
is not a Bill Clinton midterm this is
not a George W bush midterm this is not
a Barack Obama midterm this is not even
a Donald Trump midterm
this is something totally different
people out there know this
they know what's at stake
are they mad about the high prices of
things absolutely sure fine
had they had a lot of discussions about
that sure fine
have they blamed it on the wrong people
sure fine
but I believe there is one strain one
idea that is the most important here
and the Republicans have shown their
cards on this time and time and time
again rather it be when row is
overturned they cheered and not only did
they cheer they went all in on the state
absolutely Banning any kind of Rights
women have in the privacy of their
doctor's office and now they want a
National Abortion man
or it's the fact that they want to undo
our safety net for our seniors and the
disabled by getting rid of Medicare
and Social Security absolutely undoing
that safety net that we have had for
decades in this country
that okay so so it's a little imperfect
but they want to get rid of it think
about what that means
if we absolutely undo that part of the
safety net in the country
they want to absolutely get rid of all
immigration in this country
particularly with people of color
people of different religion
people who speak different languages
all together want to undo it and get rid
of it
they literally are on Putin's side
for war crimes
people know what's at stake
you know what's at stake
so communicate it engage in it talk to
folks they'll listen to you I watched a
clip from MSNBC and I was highly
disappointed
I believe it was Elise Jordan who was
leading the conversation
and I don't know why why so many people
are so interested
in how these people can believe this
stuff what is important is not that they
believe this stuff
they believe crazy ass [ __ ] for a long
time they're predisposed in American
Christianity mainly evangelicalism
to be believing an absolute garbage and
nonsense without any backing up a fact
or doubt
why would why would MSNBC
air people in a room talking a bunch of
nonsense without heavy pushback and
mocking them that's what you have to do
you don't have to be interested in their
[ __ ] bone-headedry
you have to push back
you have to lean in to the truth
not go oh that's really interesting that
you believe that oh wow tell me more no
no what you're saying is wrong
you're a [ __ ] bonehead
that is not how it works
there needs to be pushback and we need
to show them
our biggest pushback
which is to pile them under mountains of
votes folks
we are two weeks away
it's Tuesday two weeks from now we will
be talking about election day
that's where we will be at in our
country
and it's the most important election of
our democracy's lifetime
just like the 2021 was the last
and the 18 and the 16 before that
and as soon as these votes are counted
after their cast by next Tuesday
in two weeks
and the votes are certified
and those seats are placed
and hopefully the adults take back over
everywhere I know there's going to be a
wave and it ain't it ain't going to be a
trump wave they're losing folks it's all
a fraud
don't believe it
it's not worth your time
but when we actually have the adults
back in the room to do the thing that we
want them to do which is govern we want
you to govern yes obviously we're going
to have disagreements on about
government and policy
the pro-democracy arm of this country
does not agree on much
do we
I I don't agree much with other
pro-democracy people it is a thing that
happens
but there's one thing we agree on is
that we should be disagreeing we should
be having these conversations these
authoritarians Ron DeSantis Donald Trump
JD Vance Dr Oz Carrie Lake Blake Masters
Greg Abbott they don't want to have a
conversation they want to tell you what
you were supposed to do and how you were
supposed to think
and if you don't agree with them then
you're the enemy
that is not how democracy works that's
how authoritarianism works
and they've got a sweet taste of that
authoritarianism a sweet sweet taste of
it
and I said the other day that we have to
give them their off ramp well the first
thing we have to do is show them to the
off ramp
you gotta show it to them folks and
that's what this election's about
we have to do the thing that we do which
is democracy
so lean into it engage in it
you are the best audience in the world
and I do mean world we have people watch
around and listen all around the world
to the Tony Michaels podcast the best
and greatest
audience of all time I appreciate your
support you're you are you are the
reason why I am here every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific I love the
chat you guys are in the chat all the
time engaging with uh with the mods in
each other in the YouTube chat some like
the twitch chat so don't forget don't
forget to go download the Twitch app and
follow us on Twitch some people like the
chat over there you should check it out
but if not you can go to YouTube
subscribe to the YouTube channel the
Tony Michaels podcast also follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod super
important that you download every single
episode on your favorite podcast
directory rather that be Spotify Apple
Google make sure when you go subscribe
on those directories that you are
leaving a great review while you're
there the trolls are going to be leaving
bad reviews they're going to be full of
[ __ ]
so you gotta go
leave your review right if they leave
one review you got to get you and
another friend who listens to the show
to leave a review
and I gotta listen to the show and leave
a real review
they hate me because of what I say and
how I say it and because you like that I
say it that's the thing that pisses them
off the most that you are the best
audience in the world
that's the thing that pisses them off
the most
is that you come here every single day
to get that cathartic release they are
terrified of you they are absolutely
terrified of you
that's why they don't like me because I
try to engage and Empower you with the
voice with a message
so
keep steady keep fast super important
for our democracy
and we run on your support here and I
appreciate all the support you give the
support that you guys have given me in
the last several weeks has been
absolutely magnificent heartwarming in
fact I've received a lot of private
messages lately
foreign
hands down I don't know about any other
audiences but my audience is the best
the greatest
and we run on your support here and I
appreciate all the support and usually
this is where I would pet the March or
show you the tip jar but I just want to
tell you that you the reason why I'm
here is because of you
so
let's show them who we are let's show
them what we can do in this election
there's thousands of people who listen
and watch here every single day
tens of thousands that watch every week
hundreds of thousands that watch every
month
and I know you can have an effect
I know you can I know you will
so everyone stick around we're gonna go
through all these clips when we come
back in the [ __ ] list Roundup everyone
stick around don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after these messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for kicking around to the break
I got a lot of clip to go through I
gotta show you exactly why Rhonda Santos
is a [ __ ] loser because he is what a
[ __ ] lose did you watch these lips
holy [ __ ]
for all the naysayers out there that
said Charlie Christ had given up on this
race yeah boy you got proven wrong last
night
you ate a big [ __ ] sandwich if you
thought Charlie Christ was out of this
race last night Charlie Chris came and
did not [ __ ] around
absolutely did not
holy [ __ ]
I mean just absolutely embarrassed Ron
DeSantis Rhonda Santos and my co-host
Gabe Sanchez said he looked like a deer
in headlights and Charlie Christ is the
car
it was um oh boy what a little [ __ ]
Ronda Santos is
what else you gonna do I mean really
honestly Rhonda Santos has been the
governor of Florida for I don't know a
couple days
really in his entire four years he's
been the governor for a couple days
there was a few things he got right with
the hurricane relief most of it was
[ __ ] wrong the lead up to it was
wrong he still is getting it wrong
he absolutely has wasted Floridians
money on all kinds of campaign
stunts
he is not he has not done anything good
for Floridians as far as Liberty and
freedom he wants to ban math Banning
Book Fairs
can't can't stop thinking
can't stop thinking
about Children's genitalian Schools he's
absolutely obsessed a Matt Walsh type
obsessed these people are [ __ ] weird
he can't stop talking about the wall and
the Border as if Florida is on the
[ __ ] border of Mexico in the United
States
maybe he should go run for the governor
of Texas
but Charlie Crist really banded it to
him last night with the main question
that I would bet there's a handfuls of
Floridians out there want to know
whether Ron DeSantis is actually running
for governor of Florida is he going to
be the guy are you going to actually be
the governor are you going to be running
around the country running for president
and I'm I'm not opposed to Ron DeSantis
running for president by the way
I actually think Ron DeSantis running
for everyone is terrified of him running
for president I'm not I actually be Ron
DeSantis running for president
especially after last night performance
is a great thing
let's do that
he is a [ __ ] idiot
he is a lying piece of garbage
that is what he is
he will continue to be that way he will
continue to put on the Trump costume and
pretend he's Trump 2.0
you think that's good for Ron DeSantis
or Republicans
just wait just hide and watch after
after this next election how great it's
going to be to be tied to Trump again I
keep telling you Mitch McConnell is
silent
Mitch McConnell wants them to lose
I don't know if you know who Mitch
McConnell is Mitch McConnell still has a
lot of power in Republican politics
maybe not as much as he had two years
ago or four years ago or six years ago
but he still has a lot of power in
Republican politics
and he still has a lot at stake and I
hate that [ __ ] sleaze bag
[ __ ] that guy
but let me tell you something
when the establishment Republicans have
been around for decades and decades and
decades are positioning themselves to
absolutely destroy trumpism
folks
trumpism is a big trouble
big trouble they know it's not a lasting
brand
so Rhonda santis running for president
of the United States oh boy that gets me
[ __ ] excited
I'm excited to absolutely yell and
scream and [ __ ] about Ron DeSantis
every single day and expose that
[ __ ] every single day here on
the Tony Michaels podcast I would never
have trouble doing that
ever
but Floridians want to know that
Charlie Crist was the governor I don't
know if you know this but Charlie Chris
was actually the governor Florida
and he was the Republican governor of
Florida
I don't know if anyone knows that people
in Florida do
voters in Florida know who Charlie
Christ is
they know who he is
he was the Republican Governor Florida
and Charlie Crist also knows that
Floridians want an answer to the
question are you running for governor
are you running for president Ron
DeSantis and he did such a beautiful job
last night
so all you naysayers out there and again
you know who you are
You Know Who You Are and then I don't
need to point fingers and call out names
but it's enough of your defeatism
because last night proved that Charlie
Christ is not giving up in that race
he absolutely
if you want to say this I know it's
sensitive to Marco Rubio he punched a
Nazi last night I mean not literally
figuratively he punched a Nazi and I
know Marco Rubio is really upset that
people are punching the Nazis that he
has hired to work his campaign
but again
folks
Florida
knows exactly what the Governor's job is
and it's not run for president so let's
do this and Gabe Sanchez is going to be
doing this you know people are saying
that iMessage is having problems are you
guys having problems with imessage
apparently um is starting to trend on
Twitter and confirm I'm an Apple user
I think people know that
and I tell you I like iMessage
but I don't want it to go down so excuse
me why while I I message my co-host to
see if he's gonna be here for the
shitless Roundup but let's do this let's
surf the Tweety tweets and trendy Trends
everybody let's start the countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
back to the show you have reached the
shitlist Roundup where we round up all
the Tweety tweets and trendy Trends
while we wait for my co-host I want to
tell you about a movie that I watched
the other day that is absolutely
fantastic it is called the game is up it
is about
disenfranchised and disillusioned Trump
supporters who were Trump voters who
changed their minds and the reason why
they changed their minds and I'm gonna
show you a clip later on in the [ __ ]
list that MSNBC did where they just let
these people ramble on and on and on and
spread misinformation between each other
and I'll tell you why we cannot [ __ ]
allow that to happen we have to push
back on these people we have to mock
them we have to push back on their
stupidity because there is hope out
there there is an off ramp and this
movie the game is up
by Melissa Joe Peltier is is it I I
believe that it's a good way to show
someone who is a who is Maga or a q
anoner or a trump supporter it's a good
film to show him to show him that hey
there is a way out there is a way out
don't let people
intimidate you and to not believing the
[ __ ] uh let's play the trailer right
now for the game is up when you're in
the conservative media world like I was
in you are told to say every day that
Donald Trump walks on water
I was told by my bosses to only say good
things about Donald Trump I told them to
go
most of our opinions about Donald Trump
do not come from CNN or from MSNBC
orphan Fox most of our opinions about
Donald Trump come from Donald Trump
himself I'll actually get over and I
should move on by using how can you I
mean they lied about liberals lied about
Democrats lying about Trump it's kind of
hard to invest in wine
I know quite a few uh people my age who
are in the Republican Party who they're
thinking about leaving the Republican
Party they're thinking about leaving
this trumpism this phenomenon I threw up
the red flag I threw up the White Flag
as a warning that this was bad
agricultural policy and it was going to
hurt us for a long time
foreign
isupmovie.com the game is upmovie.com
you can also find it on Amazon that's
one of the easiest ways to watch those
movies you just go to Amazon and rent
the game is upmovie.com you can also go
to that website but the game is up is
the movie go check it out again it is um
it is it is a way to look through the
lens of a
disillusioned
Trump voter who has turned which is not
a bad way to look at this but let's do
this let's go to the the Tweety tweets
and tring Trends as I wait for my
co-host here he's a little late you know
it happens it happens he's a little late
um but let's let's see if we can find a
video here while we wait for Gabe
Sanchez I've got a lot of video to show
you
um well we'll wait on that one because I
know he he'll like to see that one oh
here's a great one this is uh I'm going
to show you this beginning of this this
is Barack Obama talking about leaning
into democracy oh there he is Gabe
Sanchez joins us not time you know
you're a little late no I'm just kidding
we're just we're just starting I just I
just showed everybody the trailer from
the game is up movie it's a great movie
this is a great great movie I don't know
if I've well it's the one from Melissa
Joe I I'm gonna right right I'm gonna
send it to you I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna rent it for you so that way you
can watch it and then tomorrow maybe
we'll talk about it a little more I I
recorded an interview with Melissa Jo
and I'm going to um I'm gonna I'm gonna
put a little bit of that maybe uh either
tomorrow or Thursday that way people can
see Melissa Joe talking about it but um
it is a great movie so I'll rent it for
you and I'll I'll send it to you wow so
thank you yeah well you know it's the
least I could do for you showing up late
okay let's um let's go to the Obama have
you seen this up this little ad here
Obama leaning into democracy hard but
he's doing it in the greatest Obama way
Obama has such a great sense of humor
yeah I know people know that and and he
really honestly he this just shows how
great he is in front of a camera right
like this just displays that so let's
let's watch a little bit of Barack Obama
and this ad is directed at some young
folks my name is Barack Obama I was the
44th President of the United States and
I have the best jump shot in White House
history
that's what I do I've heard a lot
recently about how voting doesn't solve
everything and I can see why you might
think that it won't make Outer Banks or
Euphoria season 3 or Rihanna's new album
drop any faster people make sending
gifts any less cool wait gifts aren't
cool anymore anyway I won't even help
you understand the most complicated
questions in the universe like why do I
know so much about Keith Davidson's
dating life but here's what voting does
do it allows you to make your voice
heard on the big issues and it
reinforces the incredible work you've
done between elections holding your
leaders accountable two years ago more
young people voted than in any other
election since the 1970s and because you
did the direction of the country change
look what's happened since hundreds of
millions of Americans received
life-saving vaccines we made the biggest
investment in history to fight climate
change we've forgiven billions of
dollars in student loan debt and we
finally released that huge report about
aliens oh sorry I mean unident
identified aerial phenomena of course it
goes on and on and of course Barack
Obama is hilarious and it's really well
written for him but not only well
written but it's well delivered but I
think it it speaks to how important it
is for people to really engage with
folks because I think in the
pro-democracy movement there is a broad
range of ideas there's a broad range of
generations I talked with um the
rational Boomer I was on the rational
Boomer podcast over the weekend
um and you should go check out that
podcast just go to Apple Google wherever
you get your podcast and search the
rational Boomer and you'll see I think
it was posted on Sunday you should go
check out that interview but he was
talking about different generations and
I told him I said you know even though
there's just this generational Gap
because me and you are both Millennials
and even though there's there's this
generational Gap we still have a lot in
common and one of the biggest things in
common is I don't know
um having a way of life like a quality
equity Liberty like those tenements and
principles really do kind of you know
hurdle over the generational Gap is that
how you view this Barack Obama video is
because he's not he's not he's not gen Z
by any means he's not gen Z no not he's
not he's not gen Z no I think
I think that Obama comes and yes uh from
what I from what I've seen
um gifts are they definitely do date the
people that use them they're not talking
about me
anyway I mean anyone like just saying I
use way too many gifts is that what
you're saying no I think I really feel
like you're accusing me I'm just saying
using too bad if you use a gif gen Z
will immediately identify you and say oh
you're so what the hell are you supposed
to do is it the meme thing now I mean
what is a meme I don't know it's just
like all right you know awkward anyway
uh but I don't know what that means
uh but what I will say is like a video
like that
especially coming from a person who has
empathy you know because again remember
empathy is something that Republicans
lack and uh one of the other things they
lack are good ideas or or rather
original ideas they all say the same
[ __ ] regurgitate it they'll take fascist
ideas try to recycle them so on and so
forth
uh Obama here is is using an approach
that Republicans just don't have in
their tool set and I don't think are
capable in terms of actually applying
right they can't be funny they they
they're only their only method or their
tool is to just like Hammer something
with uh anger and violence is what
you've seen
and a lot of like personal attacks
towards someone's appearance or their
history or whatever it might be they'll
bring up something that's totally
irrelevant to the actual topic that's
being discussed and Obama has a great
way he's got a great sense of humor you
know he knows how to make fun of himself
he knows how to make things uh
understandable and break complex issues
down and he's also just someone that
when you look and you're like oh I would
love to have a beer with that guy as
opposed to anyone else you're like I
don't want to be within a hundred feet
of that person
for various reasons whether you're a you
know a pedophile or you're someone who
wants to take away someone's rights
right or or is just completely focused
and can't stop talking about bathrooms
and people's genitalia exactly can you
imagine going to a party and and there's
someone sitting around and they that's
all they're talking about like really
man I mean I get that you you have this
weird Obsession Matt Walsh of what
you're you know this of marginal a
marginalized group and I don't know what
your weird obsession is about genitalia
but it is getting a little weird but
I'll tell you last night
Ron DeSantis looked out of his element
and he looked really weird honestly it
looked like he was holding in a [ __ ] the
whole time to me that's what it felt
like have you ever had to [ __ ] so bad
Gabe like you're you're biting your lip
and and it's I mean I've done it here on
the show a couple times I'll be honest
with you you gotta [ __ ] so bad I mean
you just you're driving home you're like
oh my God I I I'm five minutes away but
I don't know if I'm gonna make it that's
really what I felt like the look on
Rhymes his face I definitely you know
there's obviously One Clip that's been
going around which is like will you will
you commit to the four years we're gonna
show that yeah but if you look at any of
the other ones uh well here let's show
this one it very much is that like he's
like
like he it almost feels like he's like
short circuiting he's like uh
do you do you think do you think they
had him hopped up on Adderall I mean I
know there's a shortage but maybe maybe
they borrowed some in Vermont or
something because he was really he was
grinding his jaw a lot and he had these
facials Expressions
don't think that Ron DeSantis was
prepared at all I think he was gonna go
in and he was gonna have his talking
points which is like oh uh anti-woke and
anti-gay and anti this right right you
mother woke her and he thought that
would work right exactly and I think
that you know
I don't think he really anticipated the
audience reacting as like
kind of it was like a vitriol like
or they're laughing or they're booing or
whatever it might be I don't think he
expected those things to happen
and uh it I mean busy in the video but
yeah it really did backfire and I think
there's another well one more well let's
watch this one here yeah go ahead go
ahead go ahead oh I was just gonna say I
think we're seeing a trend is that a lot
of these Republicans will not commit to
more than one debate they'll do one
debate they'll get their
[ __ ] stuffed in a locker right and then
they won't commit to a second one
because now they're like okay well uh it
either will go even but don't you think
that hurts him more than it helps them
right like like because now now the
debate stands out of my because I I was
saying this earlier in the a block is
that to all the naysayers out there that
were saying Charlie Chris gave up in
this race and he thought Ron DeSantis
was going to win anyway so that you know
no one's heard of Charlie Christian why
I actually think Charlie Cristo is
waiting for this moment because I think
beyond anything else that the difference
between Ron DeSantis and and um sorry
Chris other than decency for crying out
loud but the biggest difference is
Charlie Chris understands Florida
politics I mean the guy was the
Republican Governor I mean how I mean it
wasn't that long ago that he was a
republican governor and the reason why
they abandoned him is because he hugged
Obama for Obama coming and showing
empathy to his constituents I mean he
shook his hand and they put their hand
on each other's shoulders and it was
like a hug it was a socialism
same way they the Republican party you
know pushed out and exiled uh Liz Cheney
who was like any anyone who does
anything that was against the narrative
or doubts or says right hey maybe this
is the best approach you know
right that was wrong before Trump yeah
it was it was embracing Obama at all I
mean I remember when I and that's one
reason why Chris Christie isn't really
welcome in most Republican circles
because Obama came when New Jersey got
hit by the tornado and they went down
together and they were shown together to
be leaders and like well you can't be a
leader with him he's
something I don't want to say it out
loud but he's something yeah uh-oh okay
let's watch this um let's watch this
clip where it appears around DeSantis is
really trying to hold in the [ __ ]
I thought what the governor did was a
horrible political stunt
um you know we have an immigration
problem we have a problem at the border
we need to secure the Border I agree
with all of that but it doesn't mean
that you use Florida taxpayers dollars
to Charter two jets go to Texas lie to
people to get them onto planes fly them
up to the northern part of our country
and and one of them's a one-year-old
baby
another is a pregnant woman
you're willing to use people like that
in this case they were Hispanics
Venezuelan in particular
and have them as props for your
political gain that's not the way to
change policy you can change policy and
do what's right to secure the quarter by
having comprehensive immigration reform
that's what I voted for in Congress when
you're in Congress you wouldn't do it
because
look at his face
it's just
do you see what I mean by um by him
looking
like he has to take a [ __ ] yeah it looks
like he's really holding something like
he's like
it's really bad it's really bad now of
course
um this this is an issue that we've
talked about a lot here on this show
um obviously you have family who came
from Mexico not Venezuela uh you are you
are Hispanic and this is I I know it's
close uh
it's a close issue for you at home
um just because you have experienced
some of this stuff right um you know
firsthand
but the way that Charlie Chris laid this
out I believe is just as good or better
than anyone who has ever laid this out
um and the actual non-reaction as he's
doing this from the audience while he's
doing it I think it's just as effective
I think that's why Rhonda Santos is
having such a hard time here and those
gears are turning in his head because I
think the narrative has been so far that
oh Floridians want this in other words
they wanted Rhonda Santas to spend
lorda's money to send people in Texas to
Martha's Vineyard which I believe is not
the truth yeah no I mean like obviously
there are going to be people that align
with Ron DeSantis and his fascist views
and want to use people who are seeking
Asylum as political pawns right as just
objects nothing more than that uh to own
the libs right
um but I think there are and I want to
assume obviously
you know there are going to be people in
Florida like I said that that do align
with that but I do want to believe that
there are a majority of people in
Florida who think the opposite or at the
very least uh think that we shouldn't
treat other people like that right we
shouldn't we shouldn't mislead them and
then put them on a plane somewhere else
and then be like ah gotcha you guys
clean up the mess
and then obviously later on being like
Oh actually we need these migrants and
others from a Hispanic Community to come
in and help repair and and rebuild the
communities that have been destroyed
because of hurricane Ian I mean just the
which actually is the argument for
migrants coming to this guy like right
why aren't we welcoming them to this
country if if the idea is that there's
not enough people to fill jobs in labor
I mean especially what we've always done
especially when this country itself like
I'm gonna you know I'm gonna say it
right now it is stolen land and you know
we're gonna probably that clip yeah and
Ron DeSantis obviously doesn't want to
believe that nor do all the other
Republicans but let's let's let's call
what it is it's stolen land you know uh
illegally taken from people that were
you know enslaved that were killed that
you know just all these terrible things
that were done we actually paid
reparations and still are paying
reparations for that today like right it
completely ignored for the fact that
it's like why would you do that because
oh we acknowledge to an extent that we
were responsible for these crimes that
we committed and the other thing too is
is that
everyone here in this country other than
those who are indigenous are migrants
they are the family uh descendants of
migrants right guys you look like me
right this country was founded on the
idea that anyone anywhere could come
here I mean like [ __ ] Ellis Island
come through attach your name this is
who I am I've got a new beginning and I
can pursue in the world and make
something of you right exactly you could
come with nothing and make yourself into
something right which is what your
family well that's what my family did
that's what your family has done uh now
now obviously my family came from Europe
so I look a certain way and your family
came from Mexico so again this is this
is deep-seated racism yeah and this idea
that Rhonda santis and I'm gonna play
the clip here I'll find the one where
he's talking about
it's not true that it's stolen land like
dude dude whoosh like whoa yeah that is
even [ __ ] that we have been teaching for
a long time in our schools that this
[ __ ] was stolen right like we haven't
not been teaching that this stuff is
stolen how in the [ __ ] do these people
believe this stuff but that's not what's
important what's important is that we
keep moving forward and I think that's
what Charlie Chris did last night
um and the audience agreed let me see if
I can find that clip and I think this is
uh did it do I believe this one is it
let's let's uh let's go to this clip
here
because you like having it as an issue
for political scoring in points that you
want to have for a future campaign and
let me remind the viewers he wouldn't
even answer you if he would stay for
years if you re-elect him as your
Governor you're running for governor
you're asking them to vote for you for
governor at a minimum you ought to be
able to tell them if you get reelected
you'll serve as governor Ron Governor so
we had the border that was in much
better shape in January of 2021 the
Biden Administration reversed almost
every policy that was in place and they
opened the floodgates that's why we have
the problem it's not from some Phantom
piece of legislation at more racism but
not the racism that I was looking for
right I mean you know he's like uh well
let's talk about the border and it's
like all right we're not even gonna
We're Not Gonna really address the
border of Florida the border of Florida
because that's where the governor
actually and right the the idea that
somebody's going to be I mean like just
[ __ ] just the idea that somebody is
literally floating over on a boat or
there there's a thousands there's a
caravan of boats coming into Miami and
they're all illegal and like dude no
well that's the other thing that
frustrates me about this idea that
Hispanics in Florida are buying uh
Rhonda Santos's uh [ __ ] Hook Line
Sinker because for so many years Cuban
Americans
um have really been uh Republican and
the reason why is because the Castro
regime has always been communist which
is a left-wing authoritarianism which is
any authoritarianism is bad right in a
matter of it's a left or right it's bad
um so you have you have a situation
where Cuban Americans have been
Republican for a long time just because
of the ideology and the spectrum that
people are on but this idea that Rhonda
Santa scored points with the Hispanic
immunity in Florida because he treated
migrants in Texas like pieces of meat I
think is really really stupid and the
other lie that he just told and we we've
smoked it out here on Tuesdays with
Texas Paul Texas Paul is still traveling
so he's not joining us today
um you know he went to DC so but he's
still traveling so he wasn't able to
join us but
the lie that he told that that he did
that uh that the Biden Administration
reversed all policies that's all
[ __ ] title 42 still stands the only
thing in Texas Paul has told the
audience here several times and
reiterated this the the biggest change
that the Biden Administration made over
the Trump Administration is they're
treating migrants and their children and
their families like um humans like like
just giving them human decency like
they're not caging them and making them
cover up with tin boil like they're
trying their best to make sure that when
they come here seeking Asylum they're
treated with decency
um so that's the biggest thing that has
changed the Biden Administration which
liberals and some Liberals are still
frustrated with are actually making
people turn back and go back to Mexico
right um but again again and again and
again I say these are all [ __ ] Lies
coming from Ron DeSantis
but it doesn't matter if their lies or
not and the reason why is because
there's a certain group of people in
Florida that are willing to believe them
because they want to believe them and I
don't think we should focus on getting
those people to change their minds
when we're what are we two weeks away
from an election I don't think that's
what we should be doing what we should
be doing is leaning in democracy leaning
into the truth and getting people to
engage with the truth that is the most
important thing let me see if I can find
this uh this clip about them
now let's see the Rhonda santis moment
where uh this is this is the moment
where um Charlie Chris really makes him
look like a deer in headlights I think
that's how you put it on on Twitter but
here's that moment Ron you talk about
Joe Biden a lot I understand you think
you're going to be running against them
I can see how you might get confused but
you're running for governor you're
running for governor and I have a
question for you you're running for
governor why don't you look in the eyes
of the people of State of Florida and
say to them if you're re-elected you
will serve a full four-year term as
Governor yes or no
yes or no Ron will you serve a full
four-year term if you're re-elected
governor of Florida
it's not a tough question
I died it's a fair question he won't
tell you Ron I think that's probably the
worst clip for Rhonda Santos to come out
of this debate I mean these clip that
I'm trying to find here about the stolen
land is brutal yeah it's it's just I
know it's definitely about the topic at
hand that they're discussing is
education and removing
I I believe this is it here let me play
this one I think this is actually if you
look around the country they do have
programs unfortunately well they will
take a student look at their race say
okay you're white you're an oppressor if
you're black you're oppressed and think
about what that does to a six or seven
year old kid that's wrong you're seeing
that you have people that are teaching
and actually his running mate has said
this in the past that teaching the
United States was built on Stolen land
that is inappropriate for our schools
it's not true uh and I'm happy okay
Rhonda Santos if he's walking around
wondering why Nazis and white
supremacists are supporting him this is
why Ron you're a [ __ ] racist yeah I
mean and and maybe Ron DeSantis isn't
racist he's definitely racist but even
if he isn't you look like one you're
talking like one that's how it works and
really honestly Ron DeSantis with all of
this this whole debate this whole
garbage thing where he won't answer the
question for the radians whether you're
going to be Governor or you're running
for president and then that just the
absolute at every turn he has to say
racist [ __ ] [ __ ] The Stoke his white
supremacist base Rhonda santis can go
[ __ ] himself and while we're saying that
um if you want to where Rhonda Sanchez
can go [ __ ] himself loud and proud go to
store that the Tony michaels.com Gabe
this this isn't just a design this is
now like a movement that Rhonda Santas
can go [ __ ] himself because really I
truly believe that that you were such a
Despicable piece of [ __ ] that I want you
to run for president now like I want the
American people to [ __ ] show and I I
would hope that the American people
would absolutely dunk him in the [ __ ]
trash for [ __ ] like this where he says
the lie that it's not stolen land when
we know it
it's I mean you know Republicans know
again they just like the people who are
outside uh you know cosplaying as
militia and
protecting ballot boxes covering their
face right because they know they're in
the wrong wearing a body Cam and this is
yeah and but this is another moment
where you know Republicans know they're
in the wrong because the reason they
don't want to talk about this stuff the
reason they don't want to have any sort
of and it's not critical race Theory
because we know critical race Theory
isn't taught in in grade school we know
that's not taught in high school we know
that there's something that is you know
older
but
they want to do
a a blame game of
I'm a white person and now I've got to
be equal I've got to give equity and a
voice to other people who you know even
though our constitution says that we're
all equal uh I gotta do that now like
I've been in power for so long I've had
this right this privilege but it's not a
privilege it's not white privilege guys
it's that ability whether they look at
this right they say oh well this is we
can't talk about this because we know
it's bad we know what our ancestors did
or the people that were here originally
you know raped pillaged enslaved did all
these terrible things but if we don't
talk about it out of sight out of mind
it never even happened right you I saw
someone the Indian Removal Act of 1830
you got the Trail of Tears that's
another one right what what what what
what what school in the last 30 years
hasn't had curriculum on the Trail of
Tears right and here yeah and the other
thing too is like
how much I've learned about certain
events outside of grade school and high
school right that are like he's you know
keep in mind you've got a textbook and
they're like all right this is a I don't
know 300 Pages or 400 pages of history
and you've got to go through this you're
not going to get the extensive version
if you want to learn more about it sure
you can do your research on it uh but
when it comes to textbooks they're going
to give you the very like Abridged
version they're gonna give you like a
gloss over this is what happened maybe
some details here in terms of some
battle or these generals or whoever it
might be but you're not going to learn
the actual history now what Republicans
want to do is they want to wipe
everything away they want to say don't
even talk about that because if we talk
about it then us acknowledging it
actually means that we are responsible
right like it's it's the same reason why
you like don't ever say you're sorry for
it because then it means you're
responsible that's not what's going on
here we're acknowledging yes our country
the United States of America has had a
very ugly dirty past right us as a
country are trying trying to do better
as we progress forward we don't want to
regress or yeah regress backwards and
fall within an air in a time where we
took away rights or certain people
didn't have as many rights or certain
people were considered only a fraction
of a human or a person in the United
States that's what the Republican party
wants
and they get very upset when we ever
talk about it because then they know oh
[ __ ] this country wasn't wasn't that
great before and and it's built on this
idea of of uh white supremacy yeah white
supremacy enslavement like yeah the
labor you know taking advantage of
people that way knowing that we didn't
have certain
uh writes uh for various demographics
and that's what Republican parties want
they want to go back to that because
they know if we acknowledge the dirty
terrible past that we've had then
they'll be oh [ __ ] we're doing the bad
thing again but if we don't ever talk
about it and we don't ever know about it
and the thing that Republicans want to
do isn't technically bad by their
standards right well I mean I'll give
you a good example of a piece of history
that I actually did not know until I was
a grown adult I did not know about the
Tulsa Massacre no clue never heard of it
before in my entire life and once I
heard about it I was like whoa and I was
talking to another friend of mine who is
white and he's a white man and he said
how didn't we know about this I said
dude we're white that's how we didn't
know about that yeah we're [ __ ] white
I mean the the story behind that is nuts
well but what I'm trying to say because
I'll let you tell us about what I'm
trying to the point I want to make there
is that that's what Rhonda santis and
white people are upset about is that hey
we used to live in a world where we
didn't have to know these things right
and now we're upset that we have to live
in a world where we have to know these
things and we as racist white people
feel guilty about it like I don't I I
don't
I do not have any guilt in my heart for
Tulsa I actually think it's a it's a
dark day in our country and and I
actually think that we should show
people exactly what happened there I
believe daylight is the best
disinfectant right I believe showing
white people in this country that hey
this used to happen like well that's not
right like yeah but you got to
understand what led up to it and then
maybe you'll understand how not to do it
again sorry I didn't mean I wanted to
make no no not at all I the thing I was
going to bring up is like you know
people don't know about it if you don't
know about it definitely go read about
it you know Black Wall Street and how
this whole thing [ __ ] blew up right
because it was a very successful black
community right and they white people
and it was in Oklahoma deep White
Oklahoma and and the white folks there
did not like that right I mean anything
something egregious about it exactly but
the one thing I was going to I was gonna
bring up is uh during the pandemic uh
the show The Watchman came out right it
was on HBO and
um it's
it it has its origins in the story for
the show and it takes place during the
Tulsa Massacre
and it's a key it's a key moment in the
origin of this one character okay that
is a hero to many people within a black
community for this period of time
but when that show came out and that
episode came out there was an episode
where it's like an extensive like here's
what happened and they went it kind of
tells the story of Tulsa then yeah yeah
I've never I've never seen this one yeah
if anyone hasn't seen it I definitely
recommend it it's very well done it's
very good obviously based on the graphic
novel The Watchmen there's the movie but
this is the show
in the show they they I think it's they
briefly talk about in other episodes but
there's one specific episode where they
like really go into what went down
when that show came out and when that
episode specifically came out the amount
of white people that were up in arms
that were [ __ ] pissed off about it
didn't it was it was insane why were
they man why were they mad
well because they because this was
something that was true that somebody
was shedding light on and sending out to
millions of people right so this was an
education moment within entertainment
and white people didn't like that
because you mean they didn't like the
truth being told it's almost like Ronda
Santos trying to cover the truth the
same way it's almost like he's for white
supremacy or something I don't know yeah
so these are the people these are the
people that support Republicans these
are the people that support Ron DeSantis
that don't want any moment
for for black people or any minority to
have equal rights or to be successful in
this country even though this country is
founded on that principle that we're all
equal that we all have opportunity we
all have the the ability to pursue
happiness right but under the rule of of
white man right under the rule of a
white
self-assigned cosplaying uh
say it say cracker say it cracker
sorry I I I it doesn't affect me no no
it depends a lot oh you're gonna get a
lot oh they said this can you believe
they said that wait we are we're
crackers yeah but what I will say is
those people are the same people they
get offended over a TV show get offended
over a black actress playing a mermaid a
fictional [ __ ] character these are
the same people the same people that get
upset over something that is
Make-Believe and can't wrap their head
around it
all of a sudden says
oh yeah yeah this is that nothing none
of this should be okay and this is our
guy that we want to support Ron DeSantis
which is the guy who wants to take away
your rights the guy who wants to move
you around as a pawn the guy who who
doesn't actually believe in
in the rights for all but no no liberty
for the people who don't look like me
speaking speaking of people
um marginalizing people
um this is a great pause moment I guess
I don't know what happened here on this
pause but this is going to be can a a
video of Candace Owens uh
absolutely obsessed obsessed with
genitalia the daily wire I don't know
what their daily like conference calls
sound like but I'm sure it's just all
weiner talk and genital talk I can't
even imagine what they're talking about
on their company conference calls
because the daily wires absolutely
obsessed with other people's what the
hell they have in their pants it is
getting crazier and crazier uh listen to
this Candace Owens clip so Matt Walsh is
a Nazi that's the idea right I thought
it was actually the Nazis that were into
experimentation but by the way yes Matt
Walsh yes he is I want to confirm
he is it really loud is it really loud
to you no okay good okay good
um no that's good
um I just want to stop there and confirm
for Candace Owens that yes Matt Walsh is
definitely a Nazi
um I just wanna I just want to point
this out she's certainly double okay
okay
for everyone who doesn't know her show
is on the daily wire the daily wire is
owned by Ben Shapiro Ben Shapiro as we
know is Jewish
he has come out and said you know he
wouldn't he wouldn't uh condemn Candice
for her her statements of an agreement
with Kanye West but
it was interesting that he had more of
an acceptance of what Kanye said it was
like oh well we don't know a situation I
was like oh weird one one weird how
you're very kind of understanding in
this moment of what Kanye said that was
anti-semitic but for other things you're
not
and and even though he said Candace
Owens missed a mark and wasn't right and
this and that they work together right
her show is on his Network right she
works for him right
and you're you're referring to the
anti-Semitism that Kanye West has now
got his contract with Adidas axed right
the one that said the one that said I
can literally say anti-semitic things
and Adidas can't do any like can't do
anything right and I actually I actually
want to address that issue um after this
clip right um but but I just find it
interesting what you're saying is Ben
Shapiro the owner and the the founder of
the daily wire who this show that she's
doing is on his Network and and for
everyone who doesn't know Ben Shapiro is
Jewish he he does a lot of pretending
like he is a very uh um uh he's a
proponent of his Jewish descent because
he he wears the hat and everything but
again he holds up people like Candace
Owens who hold up people like Kanye West
right who absolutely absolutely are
stoking violence towards Jewish people
and
um me and Gabe actually and and and and
forgive me Gabe I don't mean to make
this about a private conversation that
we had because Gabe taught me something
in a private conversation that we had
because I was calling Jewish people Jews
and I think I I think I was wrong in
that effect and I don't think I was
wrong I just think I was misinformed and
really really I didn't know what me
saying the calling Jewish people Jews
actually did
um and I and I want to have this
conversation if you're willing to have
it I think it's worth it
um because Gabe taught me a little bit
in a back and forth and the reason why
there was a clip of someone and I think
it was Michael Rapaport saying if you're
if you're not Jewish you can't call
Jewish people Jews that's not a thing
and I thought Michael Rapaport was just
being a little over the top but I sent
it to Gabe I said what do you think
because I was referring to Jewish people
as Jews because I didn't think it was a
derogatory term right and I still don't
think it's a derogatory term but tell
tell the audience what you told me
because I I think I think it really
changed my perspective of that word and
how to use it and where to use it and
why I should or should not use it yeah
so I mean I you know Michael Rapaport
says uh you know if you're not Jewish
then don't say Jews don't say Jew you
know say Jewish people Jewish community
and I and I I 100 agree with that you
know especially
it is one of those things where you have
to listen to what those in the community
are saying they're like if I don't feel
comfortable with the way that this is
said
um you know like I don't want to be
referred to as Jews or I don't want to
refer to a Jew or I would rather be
referred to as Jewish people from
someone who is not Jewish
um
always like always go with that always
listen to the community that is is
speaking up about that and so for me you
know I've got friends who are Jewish
that I grew up that front of the Jewish
community
and so I just always was like
you know this is my Jewish friend
you know uh he he is Jewish right from
the Jewish Community you know whatever
it might be
um
because the way that I looked at it is
the way in which you call someone if you
said Jews or Jew is the way that the
same the same way that I interpret
somebody saying blacks are black right a
black or the blacks or whatever like the
Jews a Jew right because because it's
not about the word itself right it's
about maybe the aim that it sounds like
right right right and I also do think
that there's obviously like it does have
a negative connotation to it based on
the way that it's been used in a
derogatory offensive way to targeting A
specific group which is like you know
you've got a group that
African-Americans the black community
enslaved and and taken advantage of for
hundreds of years against their will
right and then you look at Jewish
Community who as point two percent of
the world population the Jewish
Community is 0.2 percent just give you
perspective of when people say oh the
you know uh uh say yeah well what what
Republicans like to say is they go the
Jews are controlling the media this and
that right they're saying these crazy
conspiracies margin Taylor green are
going to blame Jewish people for
controlling these things the cabal all
this Jewish race lasers and all kinds of
right right stuff so that is that type
of rhetoric is anti-Semitic when they
say the Jews are doing this or Jews or
that or whatever you know the blacks are
doing this Black's this like when they
say those things that is is derogatory
it is offensive because of the history
the way that I look at it and the way
that other people have you know I've had
discussions with is the way that they
look at it is when you have someone
using that term term especially based on
the history which is you've got a group
that was enslaved and for hundreds of
years and also you've got a group that
was literally
there was a holocaust right genocide
millions of Jewish people were killed to
now saying that we've got point two
percent of the world population so when
I look at that I go I you know I don't
feel comfortable saying that because one
those in the Jewish community
would would prefer and and like others
who are not in the Jewish Community say
Jewish they are Jewish it is Jewish
Jewish person Jewish what have you just
like someone from the black community
African-American Community don't want to
be referred to in something that's just
the word right right well and I that's
that's why I I uh I put it and and I had
the conversation with you privately
because I because I I have a friend of
mine who who would grew up Jewish and
she was we were talking one night and
she said because she lived in a Jewish
Community very heavily Jewish Community
she went to the Jewish Church she went
to a a school that that was mostly
Jewish or Jewish friends there wasn't
many people outside the Jewish community
in that in that school and she said and
because I know a lot of derogatory terms
living in White America I mean I've got
a ton of derogatory jokes that I've been
told in my life but there's a lot of
phrases that people use too
um and and I could I could list you you
off a hundred of them but I'm not going
to today but one of them that she was
expressing in a conversation because we
were kind of having a conversation about
Kanye West because I wanted to know what
her take was because I'm I'm not Jewish
right I'm not Jewish
um so I wanted to know what her growing
up as as a person in the Jewish
Community how she felt and she was a
little she was a little different than I
thought she would feel about it really
she didn't give a [ __ ] what Kanye West
said
um she knew the truth but she said there
was one thing that came out of
conversations that she heard which was
um the phrase Jew you down and she said
she'd never heard that until she was an
adult because she was in a Jewish
community and she said the reason why I
never heard it and I never knew I didn't
know what the hell it meant when someone
told me I had to ask someone is because
they don't say that to each other right
right and that's what really when
Michael Rapaport released the video
it made me send it to you and say you
know maybe I'm what I'm saying what I'm
saying maybe is wrong because I don't
believe that the word Jews is a bad word
I don't think it's derogatory but you
definitely if in a private conversation
if your friend says I don't want you to
call me Jewish I want you to refer to me
as a Jew then then you should do that
but in public it may be a totally
different discussion that's why I want
to have the discussion yeah and I think
it's important the the other thing I
want to add to that too is
when you've got a community like white
supremacists and other people that don't
believe that certain communities you
know minorities who what have you should
have certain rights right
when they use the certain uh we'll say
tonal
uh uh versions of a word right the way
that they they they they attack you well
we talked about this in the chat with
the word Mexican because you've seen
this because Mexican is not inherently a
derogatory term right I I mean I don't I
mean obviously people can say that right
they can call me anything you know they
can say different thing they can call me
a wet back and things like that from
people who cross over the Rio Grande
there's a lot of things that people can
say against you know the Mexicans or
even the Hispanic Community but if
there's not the same type of derogatory
way obviously again that's another
example of when someone could say
something in a in a in a different tone
that right because that's what I asked I
said is it the context or is it the
actual word and you were saying it's not
really the word it just has that
negative feel to it out loud the other
thing too and the reason that I think is
a big deal is because when you have
people who are white supremacists right
the way in which
you know you you Fuel That Fire is
you're giving it oxygen right so if they
say Jews Jews whatever and they're using
in derogatory words it becomes you've
got a group you've got a community that
is using it in in everyday household
common knowledge right they're saying
this word again and again and again
if more people who are not who who don't
mean in any way derogatory or they don't
mean in any way offensive they say you
or they say Jews or whatever it becomes
even more commonplace or now there's
another group of people who didn't mean
it offensively is now saying it so now
it becomes something that's like oh well
I just said it because I said it and now
it becomes this this whole group which
is both the people who mean it
offensively and the people who don't
meet it offensively are using it and it
becomes more and more and more and more
and it spreads that way and I think
that's another way that I would look at
it is
by allowing or accepting people from
outside that Community to use that form
of that word whatever it might be
you make it more
commonplace and the more people that use
it are going to then make it more
acceptable which is here's a prime
example of racism here's a prime example
of it from Jeremy on Facebook of course
Jeremy is a [ __ ] troll
um here's a prime example of it he was
asking Gabe if he's Mexican and here's
here's the prime example of it and this
and this is what I want to have a
conversation about and the reason why is
this because Ben Shapiro just like you
said with the daily wire is making sure
to give Candace Owens a voice which
automatically gives Kanye West a voice
in this argument yeah on the 405 in Los
Angeles California there was a big sign
on a overpass that said Kanye West is
right about Jews and people were holding
up the Nazi salute
and Jeremy here thinks it's funny to
refer to Gabe and ask him are you
illegal well not only that Jeremy's also
asking me to show my papers right see
see and and again again Jeremy you're a
[ __ ] racist and this is what we're
trying to talk about and and I'm going
to show a clip from MSNBC where they
don't come back this stuff this is why
I'll come at you Jeremy I don't give a
[ __ ] dude number one you're probably not
even who you are in the picture you're
probably really
um I don't know what time it is in
Russia right now
um but the thing is is what you don't
understand what you don't understand is
that not only is Gabe Sanchez not
illegal he's an American citizen who was
born here who was born here and not only
that not only that what you also don't
know Jeremy if you go back and look at
where the Mexican border used to be you
would understand that a majority of the
Southwest part of the country is
actually stolen from Hispanic people
right and that is why so many Mexican
descent people who live in that part of
the country have been Americans before
Americans were there and the reason why
is because they're from that land you
are a dumb [ __ ] and you love to
show it and I'm so glad you loved to do
that because that see there again a
legit question he said it many times on
the show that he's from Chicago dummy
here's the thing people like Jeremy
Jeremy Johnson I don't know if that's
your real name who knows maybe you're a
bot mayor you know maybe obviously
you're a troll you're you're [ __ ]
racist right uh okay from the bottom of
my heart Jeremy
you can go [ __ ] yourself
just want to say that as nicely as I can
with a smile on my face because you are
a living embodiment of everything that
is [ __ ] wrong with Society you are a
racist bigoted homophobic transphobic
you're probably closeted in some ways
and afraid of your own sexuality or
non-confident hiding behind a keyboard
and you have to attack people on a show
who are actually willing to say the
things that you're afraid to say in
person so again Jeremy Johnson you can
go [ __ ] yourself and I hope you [ __ ]
yourself all the way [ __ ] to hell now
the other thing I want to add
is that Jeremy Johnson wants to question
my citizenship whether I'm really an
American whether I was actually from
this country or whether I'm really where
I'm from from you know that type of
language Jeremy Johnson
I want to see your papers yeah show me
where you're from I want to know exactly
where you came from Russia yeah how do I
know that you're not someone who
illegally came to this country and is
not residing here illegally against
a Visa against a you know against of
just visiting right I want to know
exactly who you show the birth
certificate Jimmy
show me Twitch twitch wants to see it
show the birth certificate if it's not
racist to ask someone for their papers
let's see yours yeah but what makes you
what makes you inherently so American
let's see your papers are are you
illegal are you illegally here now again
this all bleeds into this bathroom
genitalia thing that's this same stoking
of fear where where someone's like oh
his last name is Sanchez so he must be
illegal whereas this person questions
their identity questions their gender
they must be a monster right I don't
know if Candace Owens knows this or not
yeah but transgender people have existed
throughout history like they have been
around forever this is not a new thing
this transgender it's not new
and the reason why they're terrified of
it is because those people don't have to
live in hiding anymore when people like
us show them decency and empathy and
welcome them into society with open arms
equality and Equity so the reason why it
is so
um I believe on the minds of these
bigots is because now these people are
not scared to show who they really are
to call themselves transgender right for
so long before because Matt Walsh
doesn't know what a woman is
um I mean he's running around the
country asking everyone what what is a
woman I don't know
but the the thing is is that
now they are able to actually live in
society for who they truly are which I I
think is what everyone should be able to
do right but these people absolutely
want to ridicule them and it's because
of their own their own misgivings here
but let's watch Candace Owens be
absolutely obsessed
about genitalia it's [ __ ] weird
pretty sure Hitler had a lot of
experiments uh that were taking place he
experimented on twins he experimented on
children so no you are not on the right
side of this issue in fact I would never
ever want somebody recording me
supporting that radically supporting
gender mutilation gender reassignment
surgery by another name it is a stunning
rebuke of our society that people don't
recognize this as wrong you know it's
it's incredible that people can become
such ideologues that they are committed
to this as if it's a cult and it's a
religion right they they wake up every
day and they say I have to get down to
the state capitol and I need to stand up
to this man who's essentially saying
what Matt Walsh is saying is allow
children to grow up right allow children
to become adults or an adult you want me
to let your own body that's not what
he's saying at all that's not what he's
saying you piece of [ __ ] what he's
saying is I don't care if it's a child
an adult even someone who wants to dress
up in a costume and perform right they
are not even they're not even for
someone performing as if they are the
other gender
that that they are not saying anything
about children they are obsessed with
children's genitalia but it's not just
children
it's not just children it's ridiculous
let's continue it's not really my
business right it really is my business
but the idea that we should be seeding
children with the notion that is a Lie
by the way it is a lie tell a child that
they can pick their gender is a lie to
make a man believe that if he gets
breast implants he's suddenly a woman
right
despite this by the fact that we know
that it is a Lie from the top to the
bottom of our society and our culture we
are perpetuating the slide to the
detriment of young it's not a lie look
and again this is the lie that they're
perpetuating is as if transgender is
this new phenomenon as if trans people
just now just now exist right this is
absolutely ridiculous they did the same
thing about gay marriage lesbians gay
men for the so long like oh it's just
now a thing that is such a [ __ ] load
of [ __ ] it's the same nonsense and the
same lies that Ron DeSantis is trying to
tell about this country is not built on
Stolen land
it's a [ __ ] lie it's a lie and we
need to call them out and that's why I
want you to see what these these these
weirdos are saying about your children
because let me tell you something this
is not just candy someone's talking
folks
Candice Owens in manipulating I believe
her and her husband are manipulating
Kanye West who has a huge megaphone so
much so that Adidas is willing to torch
almost a billion 1.2 billion dollars
worth of business globally
over words that Kanye West said that
Candace Owens has put in his [ __ ]
brain which really honestly that the
Adidas story everyone's a little upset
with Adidas because it took him so long
really
um I'm sure there's a lot of legal
contracts that the attorneys had to go
through they should have made a
statement uh early on that they were
reviewing this process I think that's
the the mistake they made is they they
didn't let people know hey we're
reviewing this
um to figure out how to undo this
relationship they've announced
officially that they are going to undo
their relationship apparently they found
a way in the contracts to undo that
relationship I I would imagine that
Kanye West is certainly going to sue
over this oh yeah but I I wouldn't I
wouldn't bet that that Adidas has
probably bound to sue Kanye or counter
Sue however yeah I mean I'm sure I'm
sure I mean yes it is one of those
things where it's like all right it took
10 days for them to actually from the
point at which he was like I could say
all this stuff and Adidas can't do [ __ ]
right challenging them
um
yeah it did take him 10 days which
obviously 10 days it feel it can feel
like a long time especially when there's
a community that is already being
targeted right the Jewish Community is
already being targeted there was a rise
in anti-semitic attacks during covid uh
and even last year there were stuff you
know attacks in New York and attacks in
LA and things like that
um but the one thing that I will I will
talk about is how
they are removing this right I think I
think the the value of uh of Kanye's net
worth after losing all of these
uh if they're losing all of these uh
deals I think he's gone from 1.5 billion
dollars in in total worth uh or I think
it was over that yeah to 400 million I
mean even the deal with Adidas was the
biggest one right they're accepting this
loss because they know at the end of the
day this is the wrong thing to do now
whether they did it based on profit they
actually believe in this we know that
obviously Adidas was something that was
you know outfitted for the Hitler Youth
so they do have a tie to the Third Reich
if anyone wants to look it up feel free
um and it took it did take them longer
than than it should have right 10 days
does feel like a long time again it does
feel like a long time especially for a
community that is being already being
targeted but especially when we've got
people here in La like Tony was saying
on the 405 that have the same let's go
Brandon [ __ ] Nazi banners this one's
saying we stand with Kanye Kanye's right
you know Jewish people or the Jews or
whatever don't should not exist right
you have that anti-Semitism because
again just like but Trump people felt
like it was okay to do these things to
make these hateful attacks to be uh
racist bigoted homophobic transphobic
anti-semitic whatever it is
and when you've got a big voice and an
influential person like Kanye that's
saying this and nobody
like Adidas you know they're taking
their time they're not saying anything
they're not doing it they're not acting
on the contract
it makes a lot of people think that it's
okay right it's the same reason why you
know if you have enough people saying
Jews or Jew it becomes commonplace and
then people are just I'm just saying the
word it's not you know it becomes this
whole kind of argument that way and the
other thing too is on the Adidas
contract I wouldn't be surprised if you
know I feel like if somebody's
disparaging your brand like this is a
representative of your company your
brand and they are saying negative
things not necessarily by your company
but in general and that brand is tied to
your brand and they're bringing you down
I mean I don't know why it took 10 days
but I wouldn't be surprised if there was
a very open and shut case for Adidas to
say this person is saying this [ __ ]
and it is negatively impacting our
company's value and the people that
perceive Us in the public and we have
the right to break this off and remove
that person so that we can now uh rid
ourselves of that that poison or that
cancer right and that's what honestly
and that's the same thing that we need
to do here in this country Republicans
are running for for all these different
seats we need a [ __ ] scalpel that
[ __ ] out and remove them Exile them into
if they want to run their own [ __ ]
country somewhere else or their own
state or whatever go do that [ __ ] and
we'll try that somewhere burn the [ __ ]
down they will do that on their own
why I mean I mean we even see it in the
UK where Liz trust takes over attacker
they are they want they want um they
want to absolutely Implement
conservative tax ideas I mean they they
want to destroy the economy and it took
44 days for them to realize that that
was all [ __ ] now they have another
conservative which he's going to do the
same exact [ __ ] it's going to be the
same [ __ ] thing here probably is not
going to last but listen folks it is so
important it is so important over the
next two weeks that you talk about this
election that you talk about voting if
you can early vote go early vote if you
have a mail-in ballot make sure now
don't wait make sure now
is that you get this it is so important
gay bad I don't mean to switch on this
topic at all but um I've got I've got
something I want to show everybody
because we had a great loss yesterday in
this country I talked about it in the a
block and I know you tweeted about it
here
um you said the incredible talented and
funny lesla Jordan has sadly passed away
his videos brought me and many others so
much joy and laughter during lockdown
um rest in peace um this is one of the
most um
I guess famous videos from Leslie during
lockdown he was on Tick Tock all the
time that's how I was actually re
introduced to him
um he's such a great performer he's not
just a comedian he's not just funny yeah
his voice is absolutely recognizable I
mean I yeah I remember watching him uh
when I was younger on Will and Grace
right I mean it's a sitcom so it's
already like fast paced right but his
banter is like sassiness and his banter
and his wittiness was oh he was in so
many things I didn't even know he was in
and that I've seen that that was him
yeah yeah I had no idea but I was
reintroduced to him like you said during
lockdown through his Tick Tock and he's
so [ __ ] hilarious right he's so
hilarious so funny but he's such a great
performer some of my favorite videos are
of him he's just like he turned the
camera on he's just like dancing and
he's just like turning and twirling and
he's making noises and he's kind of
singing because he's not he's not just a
he's not just a great comedian but he
was a great dancer a great singer and
just a great performer all around and
it's sad to hear that we lost
um such a great decent human being
um that has such a great talent but
let's play this the well [ __ ]
um famous video here
well [ __ ]
what are y'all doing screwing
there was an article in New York Times
for six during the pandemic
I said the best is Master push my God
I'm 65 I can't even do the hair taste
time still involved
I bet there'll be a lot of babies born
nine months be Christmas babies
I feel like y'all all out there screwing
and here I am just sitting
well
screw on
screw
as long as gifts are a thing as long as
they don't get too unpopular
um that that gift will live uh forever
and ever and ever
and ever and ever and ever and ever and
ever and ever yeah you know what I got
another video I want to play here our
friend Kenny he's such a great he does
great videos he's got that he's got that
energy that I like almost the [ __ ] him
energy you know what I mean but here
he's here he's talking about um black
voters uh voting Democrat and this
person says serious question for black
people
why does your community typically vote
Democrat let's let Kenny to Ronald too
real tell us why do black people
typically vote Democrat I don't get it I
would have you noticed an uptick of this
[ __ ] that's been showing up on your
for you pledge you're being black you
know it's weird that all this keeps
popping up right when we're about to pop
onto this [ __ ] election that's going
to happen in two weeks but you know as
old as this man looks you would think
you would know the answer to this
because you know he might be 30 you know
being a white and agent is an epidemic
within itself but I'm gonna go ahead and
give you the history lesson anyway but
not for you but for the black people who
are watching this now technically
Democrats and Republicans didn't flip
the switch into the 1930s it started
with FDR but I ain't trying to go back
that far now he didn't pass the New Deal
and then we were looking at him pull
ourselves out of a [ __ ] depression
but black folks were still reflecting we
weren't sold on the [ __ ] okay we were
still reflecting we were like an old
damn harm dog because we were giving our
loyalty to the Republican party because
the Emancipation Proclamation even
though they had already switched
platforms becoming more corporate
capitalistic now the real momentum
didn't happen to this [ __ ] 60s baby
during the Civil Rights Movement LBJ was
the [ __ ] Lyndon B Johnson Democrat by
the [ __ ] way his ass passed the
Civil Rights Act he created Medicaid and
Medicare not only that he pass the hate
crimes bill into law and not only that
during his administration the Supreme
Court wind up ruling that the ban on
contraceptives was unconstitutional and
then he took it a step further by
appointing the first black Supreme Court
Justice by Thurgood Marshall now black
people weren't blind [ __ ] we were
seeing all the [ __ ] and guess what we
did we switched but let's keep going
it's interesting to me that y'all want
to rewrite history and blame Bill and
Biden for mass incarceration When The
War on Drugs started with Reagan now I
know this old ass [ __ ] was there
in the 80s in the [ __ ] 90s okay
he looked like he was probably 20 in the
1920s now you ain't gonna sit here a lot
of me and act like the Congressional
Black Caucus and black churches wasn't
in support of the [ __ ] crime Bill and
since we talking about Big Bubba Bill
let's talk about all the [ __ ] he that's
not diminish his accomplishments with
just a [ __ ] crying Bill let's talk
about he appointed the first historic
judge to the Circuit Courts of appeals
in Richmond Virginia not only that black
poverty decreased by 22 [ __ ] percent
and we had a surplus [ __ ] and for the
moment you've been waiting for let's
talk about Biden you know he might have
a complicated past but I don't want to
talk about what was that that's about
what's now during the Obama
Administration who was his Vice
President Biden and what did he test
Biden to do to save the Auto industry
who was working for the Auto industry
black folks not only that they wanted to
address the War on Drugs so they passed
the fair sentencing act lowering the
disparities between grack and powder by
80 [ __ ] percent they passed the
Affordable Care Act when they know that
black people struggle with more
pre-existing conditions than any other
ethnicity in this country now that
Biden's president he passed the Emmett
Till anti-legic bill after 200 failed
attempts he appointed the first black
woman Supreme Court Justice contagi
Brown Jackson not only that vice
president come here is making history as
vice president and we lowered it child
poverty by 42 [ __ ] percent with arp
he always comes with the heat always
with the heat no Kenny Kenny is uh is is
comes in two two hot two but two raw too
real too raw too real he comes in no I
mean like Kenny Kenny he's like
100 no filter don't raw and real and
gives you the [ __ ] to like here's the
thing I guarantee if you you could have
given I mean I don't know what the time
was on the total video because I know it
was from a tick tock so I know like you
know uh you can only go so long yeah
there's a part of me there's a part of
me that's like he didn't even discuss
what happened during Obama right right
he skipped Obama
I'm sure you could have talked about a
lot of things I mean they did talk about
the Affordable Health Care Act they did
about the saving Auto industry you know
didn't talk about the recession you know
uh there was many many more things that
happened during Biden in the last like
three months too right people were
saying we should get Kenny on we should
get Kenny uh I have been in in chats
with Kenny DMS yeah so we've been
chatting let's just figure out the
schedule of when he can come on the show
but great great he did say yes and he is
interested so we're going to try and get
him on the Fantastic
um but yeah it's one of those things I'm
sure if you gave him more time he would
[ __ ] just go off on everything which
is great because that is the energy we
need right and that is the energy that
that Kenny brings to a lot of these
conversations where he's like look this
is what is at stake you cannot sit by
the sidelines you cannot then say this
this uh defeatist
um uh uh ultimatum type of of
of attitude you can't be like well it's
already been decided because I know
there are certain programs on the
internet that definitely take that
approach and that's not something we can
do right now like I don't want to you
know we're like I said yesterday
regardless of the outcome regardless of
what
um whatever happens in this election you
should not approach it with the idea
that it's um
we have no chance or walk in with it
what it's already
it's already done it's already done in
the means of like oh this has already
been decided it's clearly blue it's
clearly gonna go to the democrat's way
no do not take either approach you gotta
go to the polls like everything is at
stake because it is you cannot say it's
uh defeatist it's done whatever you
cannot take the assumption that it has
already been decided because it's been a
blue area you have to go in
assuming that everything is on the
[ __ ] table because it is
and right now as we say you know it this
is one of the most important elections
and obviously 2024 will be another
important election it's going to keep
getting to a point you know
I'm sure people get old of hearing it's
the most important election it's the
most important election but here's the
thing it is there was so much at stake
there was so much that this Republican
party is trying to do and remove and
strip away
they've already been able to do that
under a Democratic president but they've
had Republican majority or in the sense
of
decides that they can take right they
have more power than than just Democrats
having a 50 50 split or a 51 50 split in
terms of having Harris as as someone
who's a deciding factor people they want
to know people want to know how to
follow Kenny I put the uh the his oh
yeah but his Twitter hand I put his
Twitter handle in the chat sorry no no
yeah it's uh at two raw too real and
it's a two like number two
r-a-w-t-o-o real like it's real but
basically what I'm trying to say is that
is the type of energy you should take
that uh [ __ ]
will will not give up will not accept
defeat you have to go to the polls and
vote like your life depends on it
because at the end of the day there are
some people's lives like women and those
who are not white their lives do matter
their lives are at stake their rights
are at stake and just because you think
right now oh it's only that group right
now it's only that group
yeah sure it's only this group right now
but sooner or later that group you know
Republicans are going to say ah you know
what actually we should take away those
rights and those rights and then you've
got yourself with a white guy you know
Tony talks about trying to buy condoms
at a at a at a gas station he can't or
you know a white person trying to do
something else and be like dude those
things were taken away ages ago those
rights you don't have those rights
anymore and all the people that were
simping for these fascists and these
right-wing terrorists and all these
other [ __ ] people are gonna find out
that they are on the chopping block as
well they're gonna find out when they
look around and say whoa whoa whoa whoa
guys what happened
I I was I was with you guys I was a part
of you right and they're gonna say no
you're not rich you're not white you're
not old you're not this you're not that
you're setting me up for the next story
you're so great great you actually
tweeted out you said what the [ __ ]
I would also like to know why Marco
Rubio has a white supremacist working
for him in his Senate campaign against
Val demings care to comment Marco uh
Chad loader they post posted this
um under a Marco Rubio post and they
said hey Marco Rubio is this your
campaign stamp for wearing a uniform of
white supremacist group league of the
south at the deadly 2017 unite the right
rally in Charlottesville saying they
will not replace us
um we've heard this story of a of a
Marco Rubio they've been playing this
[ __ ] on Fox news on all the Republican
media Outlets all the trader TV news
outlets that Mark one of Marco Rubio's
um campaign staffers got his [ __ ] ass
kicked in the neighborhood that he was
not welcome in that's the way they
present it right and he was hospitalized
at his ribs broken but let me tell you
something if you showed up into certain
types of communities and you were
talking like this let me listen let's
listen to this guy speak
I intend to stand for the South and dive
forward of DB
if you go to certain communities and you
talk like a Nazi it probably is not
going to fare well for people who I
don't know probably like to punch Nazis
right and this guy [ __ ] around and
found out I'm sure now they said like oh
he was attacked because he has a Marco
Rubio shirt on nope he was attacked
because he's a [ __ ] Nazi you got it
got it let me tell you something this is
the common misconception that the right
has about the left
that the left is going to is going to
capitulate and tolerate this level of
intolerance it is not going to happen
it's not going to
and I believe this is a perfect example
of that and the right wants to cry and
whine about how this Nazi got his ass
kicked because he was out being a Nazi
and and stumping for Marco Rubio
um but let me tell you something let me
tell you something if they think that
that this country people who are
pro-democracy are just going to stand
back and let them Edge their way in and
take away it take away this democracy
from us I doubt that they're going to be
um I doubt that they're going to have
surprise when it meets them with what
this guy got met with what's your take
on it
no I think this is really one of those
moments you know just like Kanye you
know he [ __ ] around and he found out
in terms of Brands dropping him there
aren't
people think you can say or do things
without consequences right right you had
the freedom of speech but not Freedom
you could say whatever you want however
bigoted transphobic homophobic
anti-semitic thing that you want to say
sure fine go ahead and say it but Watch
What Happens whether it's a person on
the street that's gonna [ __ ] knock
you out and hold you accountable or the
legal system will hold you accountable
for whatever action you do right whether
you're you're committing a hate crime or
you're you're attacking a certain group
of people right
people like this guy that was you know
working with Marco Rubio that was one of
his staffers they wanted they want to
take the they want to play victim they
want to say oh they attacked him you
know they attacked my staffer because
they had a Marco Rubio sure no one
[ __ ] cares that much about Marco
Rubio who's Marco Rubio most people
don't you know he didn't even I can do
anything I don't I can tell you I can
tell you yes is he real yeah I can tell
you this probably for 100 certainty
there is neither a person that supports
Marco Rubio on his side that would that
would fight for Marco Rubio just fight
for Marco Rubio just like there was no
one I mean like I mean like you mean
like physically right there was no one
on Marco Rubio's staff or on the
opposite side that I guarantee would
actually physically fight just for the
name of the person Marco Rubio this guy
who's you know Little Marco Rubio
sipping water No One's Gonna actually go
out and have a bar fight on behalf of
that dude what they are gonna fight for
are the things that Marco Rubio and
other Republicans support right by not
condemning racism right or anti-Semitism
or whatever other big history there is
just absolute white supremacist nonsense
and they will they will they will fight
for that they won't fight for the person
but they'll fight for the ideologies
that they represent it's called trumpism
um that's that's trumpism in in in a
nutshell speaking of morons who are weak
um and to play tough guy but are weak in
public this guy Alex Stein do you
remember this guy Gabe Alex Stein you
didn't know what was that on him he was
the guy who was sexually harassing AOC
um this guy is such a shitbox what a
[ __ ] box now he was trending today on
Twitter and there Gabe the reason why
he's trending is because he's a punk ass
[ __ ] is what he is he's a scared little
punk ass [ __ ] just like just like the
proud boys founder Gavin McGinnis is a
punk ass [ __ ] and frankly that's why
they were dreaming they were trending
because they're punk ass [ __ ]
together now they went to Penn State to
talk and to spread around white
supremacy and hatred okay now this
Tucker Carlson looking [ __ ] is
met by a crowd watch how he's acting
here watch how tough he's acting In This
Crowd what's this
[Music]
he's so scared it really seems like him
and Kanye really should seek the same
sort of mental health I don't know what
do you think I want to show you another
video here go ahead give me your
thoughts while I'm pulling up this other
I mean let's let's call Alex Stein what
he is right he uh is a bigot who is an
opportunist okay and he is seeking fame
makes sense in the Limelight we know
that he is a failed comedian a failed
reality TV star a a on multiple
occasions he's a successful sexist and
misogynist and sexual harasser by the
way we've seen him on on tape and not
only uh toward AOC but also when he was
a a reality TV wannabe sexually
assaulting women on camera and making
them feel uncomfortable and then
everyone else being oh dude's a joke you
know and obviously his reaction is uh at
the time he's like it's 2012 get over it
all right he doesn't like us by the way
either no he knows who we are right he
he blocked both of us on Twitter right
because he's such a little [ __ ] well
also as soon as I release that what was
that and it got spread around I got
blocked almost immediately once again on
his radar and then he had and then
because here's the thing nothing I said
was false I brought up his past I
revealed the things that was on in
public I got some stuff that wasn't in
the public but in private Google search
is a [ __ ] I know and I brought
those things up he got so [ __ ] pissed
and so [ __ ] upset that he blocked me
and then on top of that he was sending
people to report my video because it
contained sensitive material which is
what he was right which is uh him being
there's there's irony here and a
sensitive guy reporting the sensitive
material I don't know I was just I was I
nothing I said was false I didn't make
anything up I just brought up his past
and I just brought up the things that he
did in public Damon's here says he's a
Tucker cuck which is a pretty
appropriate he's been on Tucker's show
before and it really does it really does
look like I mean he says well that
that's his that's the bit he plays now
he says oh uh many people say I'm the
illegitimate son of you Tucker when he
was on the show oh well that's that's
cute you know he hangs around with a
gang of proud boys though
um in particular the uh you can see this
video it looks kind of ominous here you
know the lights the cars it started
looks like it's almost going already in
this CL in the pause clip here
um he's he's such a [ __ ] that he blocks
us on Twitter because I don't know we we
just expose him Jeremy just quickly
Jeremy Johnson says uh the cuck over
here says you got censored
sure yeah anyone any you can block
anyone that is your right but what I
find uh funny and obviously hypocritical
Jeremy is that when you've got a person
who promotes First Amendment rights and
gets upset with other people block him
and other uh other people who are
lawmakers don't want anything to do with
them and they try to ignore him he gets
very upset about it gets very [ __ ]
innocent did you did you block Alex
Stein did you I didn't block no I didn't
block him I honestly I I don't I don't
have any reason to block Alex stuff no
either I mean I I don't have a reason to
block I have a reason to talk about him
because he's a he's a punk ass [ __ ] and
you're gonna see it in this video and
who he hangs out with he hangs out with
proud boys and some other white
supremacists and racist
um just just absolutely garbage human
beings garbage human beings who treat
other people inhumanely they're and they
they're bigoted it's it's disgusting
really
um but you're gonna see
a couple people running this car like
they're scared Gabe watch this video
they're terrified here
it was a distraction
hurry get in the car hurry go go go go
go go go go go go go well well they're
gonna wait they gotta wait for their
proud boy
out there there's their proud boy gotta
get him in the car have the cops protect
you
you know because you're you're so tough
you gotta have the the police protection
I mean when you're at a capital doing an
Insurrection you beat him with a
flagpole when you're making sure that
you can leave because you're a scared
little [ __ ] you want them to protect
you from all those from all those
libtards those pronoun having libtards
you people really are [ __ ] dumb
people you know who is actually so
yesterday I don't know if you saw
footage you know who was attacked at
that protest for him showing up at the
school who
uh the people who are protesting him
were the ones who got maced by uh-oh
wow so you're saying what you're saying
is actually the people who were being
actually violent was the right and
because there was such pushback these
these weak little [ __ ] uh Gavin
McGinnis the founder of The Proud boys
and Alex Stein is simp uh were running
in fear because they're scared of
consequences for their speech seems
appropriate in this day and age I just I
didn't want to leave today without
um mentioning that Alex Stein is
trending and to make sure everyone knows
who the [ __ ] that little punk ass [ __ ]
is
um so everyone go out there and get out
it's time to block you it's not really
hard you just you just say something to
him you know hurt his feelings just a
little bit I will I will just for for
people to know in about 30 seconds go to
my profile
retweet share the video that I made
about Alex Stein we'll see how quickly
he blocks you yeah quote tweet tag no
tweet take in videos somewhere he's he's
on his cell phone right now he's
probably watching this show Believe It
or Not that's because Alex Stein knows
who we are so he's probably watching the
show he's like oh God they're gonna he's
getting ready he's getting ready to
block you so if you want Alex Stein to
block you right now is the time let me
uh um are you Tweeting it right now yeah
give me one man let me go to your
profile and I'll I'll show everyone the
one that we're talking about so they
know exactly which one will get them the
the badge of honor being blocked by Alex
Stein which one to uh retweet quote
tweet and tag him in and so he knows
exactly
um who to block because I know Alex will
block them I mean he's he's very good at
that he's very good and blocking voters
yeah well you know did you hit tweet yet
no I'm about to write it right now now
now right now and for all those
listening you can go to at I am Gabe
Sanchez oh wait hold on [ __ ] did you
he's probably got a misspelling in it he
doesn't want he doesn't want anything no
no I forgot a I forgot a slash here ow a
slash oh so it's not showing the full
video yeah what's his what's his handle
I'll put his handle in there too I I
don't I can't remember I can't remember
it ah [ __ ] it's um at punk ass [ __ ]
I know I don't know a blackout is Alex
Stein 99 is still that I think it's that
I think it's Alex 9.99 probably yeah
yeah there it is there it is so if you
want Alex Stein 99 to block you Now's
the Time get in while the getting's good
go to
Gabe Sanchez's
um
okay his profile but also don't just get
Alex to block you watch this video
because Gabe in this what was that you
did a great job of exposing who Alex
Stein is and really honestly you just
all you did was a Google Search and went
and found some video of the guy and just
like hey here's what it is I mean I
didn't it's not surprising this guy
sexually harassed all right there we go
it's up it's up is it up
oh there it is okay let me show it to
everybody here is uh Gabe's profile and
here's the here's the YouTube video you
can go the link is right there and meet
Alex Stein he tagged him you should not
do the same I mean unless you want in a
black even one Alex to block you
definitely yeah you should not you
definitely should not retweet it quote
tweet it right embed it in his tweets
right uh you definitely shouldn't tag
him in the video Alex Stein 99 is a
handle
um he'll block you if you want he'll do
yeah as soon as you as soon as you bring
this video up he will 100 hundred
percent block you ask him let's see what
can you ask him about uh you can ask him
about him sexually harassing a fellow
contestant on a reality TV show yeah
you'll see that in the video actually
you can ask him about his failed uh
career as a stand-up comedian yeah you
can ask him about which I think that
video is in there too isn't it oh yeah
yeah it's all kinds of there's all kinds
of great stuff packed oh you can hear
evidence here's one here's one I didn't
get to include you can ask Alex Stein
about the Shady Bail Bonds business that
he and his dad are a part of what if you
were to Google if you were to Google
don't Alex Stein Google Bail Bonds dad
you might find an article from
uh it's a Dallas uh article and it talks
about his dad's Shady history oh so gosh
you can bring all of these things up
there's so many many more inside right
inside the video
poor Alex Stein he's they those those
libtards were being so mean to him that
he had to run away everyone same time
same place tomorrow uh don't forget to
go to store not be tonymichaels.com and
grab your Liberty sweatshirt that
hoodies and zip-up hoodies I actually
got my damn it I forgot to show it to
everybody I got mine yesterday I'll show
it to you tomorrow I'll try to wear it
tomorrow I forget it's really [ __ ]
warm I put it on yesterday Gabe and it
was so warm I had to take it off because
like gee I was in the house I was like
good Lord this thing is warm so go grab
if you want to stay warm while you're
waiting in line go grab the zip up
Hoodie a hoodie pullover or a sweatshirt
or just grab the t-shirt for that matter
we also got coffee cups the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] so go to
store.thedonymichaels.com grab your
Liberty sweater your Liberty hoodie your
Liberty t-shirt there Gabe until
tomorrow same time same place noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch
surf sub [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon